- dango I'm Aubrey Plaza and I'm Gabriel
Bateman in honor of Mother's Day and our
upcoming horror film child's play we
wanted to pay tribute to five hormones
Oh Wendy Torrence from the shining she's
played by Shelley Duvall she's such a
good mom because she protects her son
and they're in a very large hotel I do
remember that and then there's ice moms
don't like to be cold so any mom who
would sacrifice going to an ice maids
for their son that's a good mom right
there but she fought and acts with a
knife which is not a fair fight at all
but she was just doing her best
Rosemary's Baby yep Wow Mia Farrow when
mothers have a child you get an inner
strength that allows you to lay lift
cars and fight the devil and I just love
her pixie cut because she looked cool
while she was doing it moms that fight
the devil and still can look cool while
doing it
are good moms in my book
[Music]
ah The Exorcist now this is one of my
favorite mothers Chris MacNeil played by
Ellen Burstyn who I love and I know you
love to you read her autobiography when
you were five right right her daughter
was becoming possessed by the devil
and she had to deal with a lot of throw
up doesn't matter if you have the flu or
possessed by the devil and you
projectile vomit your mother will clean
it up because she loves you
and that's what I learned from watching
The Exorcist a little trivia for you I
projectile vomit
whenever I throw up spews out just like
Exorcist I'll next up we have
poltergeist Diane Freeman is the
character of the mom played by Jo Beth
Williams basically dives into some kind
of Hell light portal and she doesn't
know what's in there it's just a big
beam of light with some time demons
screaming pulling the Chuck in your
children into this evil vortex and the
mom just doesn't think twice
she's dives right in there just like
it's a summer pool party for our last
spooky mom clip because this one's got
to go to bed we have Nightmare on Elm
Street you did your homework for once me
well I did didn't I she protects her
child by setting Freddy on fire well
that's why Freddy's
after child he's dead honey because
mommy killed him okay so she asked for
it if there was a man on fire running
after me I would do everything I can to
shove you in a closet throw out the key
and make sure that you're safe and sound
because I love you my son
no go to sleep
hi daddy
[Music]
[Music]